I'm Eric Allard on the Conan special
effects coordinator and what we have
here is the bobble head this was a an
effort of our special-effects crew our
scenic guys goo Moss our production
designer drew the picture then I took
his drawing and put it in my AutoCAD
program and then from there I designed
all the structure we passed the Warner
Brothers staff shop the sculpt and
finish they had and then we hired a very
talented sculpture who sculpted the body
according to my drawings so that
everything would defend it's all made
out of 1.8 pound density foam it's a
polyurethane foam it's a very
lightweight fine foam that's really good
for carving excuse a lot the studio's
for like architectural details and big
statuary like this after it's sculpted
it's smooth and then a hard coat is put
on made out of polyurethane resin and
some bondo just like you would finish a
car pretty much sanding bondo primer and
then the paint our painters David and
Bobby painted it the thing weighs about
2,000 pounds
[Music]
the metal shop here at Warner Brothers
have a really good facility they made a
lot of the steel that's inside it rides
on a cushion and there it has a one-ton
truck spring in it for the bobble action
what can I say
there it is ready to load on the truck
I'm a happy man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you